Lars in the one video is the first time
we really get to see your feet when
you're playing the drums and you do that
heels up thing you actually keep your
heels up high
[Music]
do that by yourself for a second I want
to point that something to people
because look it's fast
[Music]
it's almost impossible to move your feet
that fair I can't tap my foot that fast
is that because traditional drummers
keep their heels down when they play and
you decided to lift your heels when you
play is that have something to do with
it I stomp on the kick drum rather than
like you're saying have the heel
so I play kind of with the front of my
foot you're running you're running hard
and I was just getting into it it comes
from uh it comes from the from the
athletic side of my family uh just
growing up around tennis and everybody
in my family were tennis players for
soccer players do your ankles hurt when
you play that because you're playing
with your feet like at an incredible
rate of speed do you ache after the
concert no the the worst Parts generally
are more the shoulder the shoulder and
the elbows or or the the problem areas
for me the feet are not so bad if I'm
playing like super fast
[Music]
wow up in that register and playing
those fast kick drum patterns and stuff
like that that actually flows fairly
easy for me and I love the kind of what
I call the four on the floor the kind of
fill Rod you know AC DC
foreign
where you can really really lean into
the kick drum what is the hardest
Metallica song to play drum wise Lars
what is it there's two ways you play uh
some of the songs are more what I call
physical take a song like Enter Sandman
we were hitting earlier sad but true or
some of those songs play more physically
with your body the ones that are the
hardest are the ones where you have to
play with your mind where you have to
keep thinking about the next Parts where
it gets into a lot of the stuff from the
earlier Progressive albums where it's
more it's five and then it's three and
then there's a thing coming up with two
guys and you gotta remember that the
first time it's a double tail and the
second time it's a single tail a lot of
pressure
yeah let's take like the back part of
one you know so the part where we're
just playing if you're going to the next
part the double bass part's fairly easy
but then when it gets to the next part
with all those axes
[Music]
foreign
okay now you gotta go up to that Temple
then four accents then do that snare
pattern thing there that syncopated with
James's guitar that's in the head that's
not in the body
and that's the harder stuff for me than
there are some of those crazy songs from
back in the day there's a song called
Fred and Sanity some of those songs the
eye of the beholder and the shortest
straw some of those songs we've kind of
edited along the way to make them a
little less
heady and a little more physical and and
try to just continue to have them uh you
know evolve so they fit our
playing style more you know as we're
getting a little older we definitely
like the more physical stuff and I think
we're all less turned on by the stuff
that's super heady and cerebral
but like just cutting into that one
thing that we just did I mean it felt
pretty good and we haven't played that
in about four months or something
foreign